i'm going to briefly cover some of the
topics that we're going to be discussing
for this program on genomic data
analysis so
the objective of this program is really
to cover a broad overview of different
types of topics provide you with the
methods that you can practically apply
to analyze
the data genomic sequencing data but
also importantly to understand
how this can be applied to a variety of
different project examples and try it
out on your own so hopefully by the time
that you complete this program
you will understand
what the terminology means especially
when you read the papers you will also
be able to practically
have experience and know where to start
your project how the different stages
are connected to each other how to
interpret this and have a meaningful
discussion with your peers or with
others about genomic data analysis and
interpretation but today i want to
briefly start from the very beginning
later on i will show you where you can
find a lot of the information that we
cover in today's session uh but i i will
just take a few minutes to talk about
some of the basics because we typically
assume that everybody is on the same
page but you know a lot of people just
by not understanding certain types of
terms or maybe concepts it's very
difficult to follow along
so what is dna code what do we know
about the dna code and what is it that
we still don't know what is there else
that we are trying to learn why why do
people continue to study genomic data
and try to interpret and understand what
this code means
so dna code especially when we talk
about eukaryotes and we talk about
you know people
we think of this code as a book of
recipes so it's organized in a specific
structure it has sentences
paragraphs paragraphs that are organized
into chapters and so really learning
this book and how to navigate and spot
these patterns is the basics of is the
basic approach of genomics so dna is
short for deoxyribonucleic
acid
it's a long molecule that's composed of
two chains that coil around each other
and form this double helix that we all
know
and the code contains instructions
so these instructions are coded in the
human genome in about 3 billion base
pairs so it's very long not all of those
base pairs contain information that ends
up being translated into proteins and
similar approaches of uh putting
information into this code are used by
bacteria uh viruses uh you know enlarged
organisms multicellular organisms as
well
so
the same approach the same code contains
directions or recipes for what we call
life
and life
is the condition that
sorry
that distinguishes animals and plants
from inorganic matter so what does life
give us it gives us the capacity for
growth
reproduction functional activity and
continual change that precedes steps so
when we talk about life here you can see
a really nice animation or
actually not an animation in a video
where a single uh you know small
microorganism and maybe even different
kinds of microorganisms are moving right
and that's really what distinguishes
life from these inorganic uh
matter like rocks for example so
when we uh have these uh
you know the these
recipes or these pieces of code
they are organized
in a very tight
way by compressing this
long molecule
into a
very tightly compacted
kind of
you know nucleus and when cells divide
what happens is that
in the nucleus we have all of this dna
and when it divides
we can see how this dna is organized
because it needs to be unfolded
and so what we discover are these
strings that are inside and we can
actually see them so this is the process
of division and what you can see are
these chromosomes right so these
chromosomes are actually uh
you know string of dna uh also packaged
very tightly in these um you know
specific shapes so these chromosomes
contain different genes each one of our
cells contains 23 pairs of chromosomes
one of the chromosomes comes from our
mother and the other from our father and
the unique structure of chromosomes
keeps dna tightly wrapped around
spool-like proteins called histones
without such packaging dna molecules
would be too long to fit inside our
cells
so
when we think of this chromosome this
chromosome we can expand it and this is
what it looks like
so here's the actual dna this string
right here that is uh kind of
coiled around
uh these histones so if we continue and
unfold it you can see that
these are the histones and it's packaged
right around those histones
so
when we
speak about this code and what does this
code actually contain what instructions
does it contain so the product of the
code and the way that it interacts with
the environment is called a phenotyping
so a phenotype can describe a single
cell a tissue organ or the whole
organism phenotype of an organism might
include height size and activity and
phenotype of a cell might include its
specific function size and morphology or
its shape
so the code which is packaged in this
molecule defines this phenotype right
defines first phenotype of the cell then
of the organ or the tissue and then of
the whole organism right and so the the
basis of this code is all about these
nucleotides so these nucleotides are
made up of a sugar called deoxyribose in
nitrogen containing base and a phosphate
group the nucleotides are joined to one
another in a chain by equivalent bonds
that form between the sugar of one
nucleotide and the phosphate of the next
and the resulting
the the result of this structure is an
alternating sugar phosphate backbone so
each strand of dna molecule consists of
a sequence of bases that is
complementary to the base is an opposing
strain so when we say a base pair right
you will hear a lot when we speak about
genomics this term called base pair
nucleotide amino acid this is where it
comes from so a single
structure here is a base and the
connected
are base pair
this molecule can be read from both
sides you can see the three prime and
the five prime ends so you can read from
either side and this single base pair
represents some kind of a uh you know a
nucleotide so this nucleotide we would
refer to one of these adenine guanine
in cytosine
so to understand how this code works and
what is in this code as you all know
this is the famous starting point of the
human genome project you can see it was
published in the new york times on
tuesday june 27 2000 when they uh
announced that the this code of human
life is cracked by scientists right so
now scientists understand how these dna
sequences that we can now read
are organized to inform us about life
what is life how does life function how
does it produce the phenotype
now today we are in 2021
21 years later so if that happened 21
years ago what else do we need to learn
about this
so it turns out
that simply reading the code and
annotating it is a much longer process
than the human project itself the human
project itself was focused on
understanding what is in the code
and they discovered that there's only
one to two percent of protein coding
genes
the rest are non-protein-coding genes
and so we have a lot of other types of
information that is in the dna
and we now know that there is there are
a lot of questions there are a lot of
additional things to understand about
the human genome about the dna how it's
organized and how it actually works and
it's a very complex
approach that people now take to study
individual specific regions of the dna
and try to understand what is the impact
of how this code is written to describe
life and describe phenotype
so
as we spoke dna is stored in the nucleus
organized in chromosomes and specific
regions are responsible for specific
functions some of the easiest regions to
read and understand their function are
what we call protein coding genes
there's a total of
22
500 protein coding genes but even that
number continues to change
protein coding genes are the sequences
that are used to produce proteins and
then they also have a specific structure
so when we think of this code working or
producing that phenotype the way it is
done is by dna
being transcribed into rna and then
being translated into proteins
so these proteins
that are produced from dna is
facilitated by several different
proteins it's a complex kind of a
translational process
that uh you know we we will study uh in
a little detail to understand exactly
how it works but the basic concept that
we need to understand is that the
individual nucleotides or base pairs
that we saw in the dna eventually had to
have to be converted into amino acids
which is what the proteins are made up
of
and so when we think of protein coding
genes we're going to be looking at
sequences
dividing them up into triad codons
and then
looking at how those trinucleotide
codons sorry
and looking at what they mean how do
they function in terms of amino acids
so
the function of the rna polymerase is to
convert dna to rna and then the ribosome
of course converts the rna into protein
so the genome composition you know let's
just talk a little bit about how the
human genome is maybe different from
other genomes
the human genome is not the longest
genome you can see right here's the
human
grape for example is much longer not
much much longer but longer nevertheless
and uh influenza for example uh flu or
covet we all know is the thousands of
nucleotides long as opposed to the human
uh which really has uh
tens of thousands of genes uh and
billions of nucleotides so influenza for
example has eleven genes and uh you know
somewhere about twenty thousand uh
nucleotides uh and that's how many genes
we have so here you can see what types
of genes do we actually have and you can
see that nine percent so almost 10
percent of genes we don't even know what
they are but how do we know
that a gene is a gene so a gene is also
organized in a very specific way
they're not just sequences of
nucleotides they have upstream and
downstream regulatory sequences that
control transcription inside the gene
sequence itself there are codons and
introns that undergo splicing before a
gene is translated into a protein and
the length of these genes can vary
significantly and so they vary because
they have these introns that could be
very long
so when we speak about translation like
we said the translation occurs as a
result of ribosomes so here you can see
this is a microscope image of unfolded
dna you can see that the ribosomes are
these large dots right here and that is
what they look like so what happens is
mrna gets it into the dna it gets into
the ribosome and the outside of this
ribosome we already have this protein
which is a sequence that is folded
and eventually forms
a protein that looks like this
so this protein this is actually two
different proteins bound together
because proteins now have a function
they interact with each other and so in
the context of genomic data analysis we
can look at every step of the way we can
look at the dna we can look at the
impact of this dna on transcription and
we can look at the impact of dna in
terms of translation and so the ultimate
goal of genomics is to integrate
multiple
aspects of this kind of data by looking
at where the gene or genes are located
in terms of the chromosome
what do we know about the organization
of that gene and how that gene could be
translated into a protein so here you
can see that protein structure
and eventually to validate its function
through experiments so here you can see
this is the same protein this protein is
nm23h1 this is a protein that is
responsible for
control of metastasis or spreading in
cancer and you can see that its
structure is known because we have a
crystallized structure of the protein
but we also have studies that show how
this protein functions and we can
measure this in terms of
animal models
cell lines and compare and contrast how
it
works in in different variations
so when we talk about genomics in this
program we're going to be talking at
looking at data
to try to understand
what this data can tell us about a
particular phenotype and there are
several different ways that we're going
to be able to look at this we're going
to be looking at methods like multiple
sequence alignment variant calling
phylogenetic analysis we'll talk about
what types of mutations and variations
we can find which ones cause a change at
gene expression level which ones caused
the change at the protein function level
so we'll talk about all of these things
throughout this program but the basis of
this program is going to be based on
data and the data that we now study to
represent genomic variation has evolved
since the beginning of that human genome
and now we have thousands and thousands
of human genomes as well as genomes that
are representative of
pretty much a lot of organisms that you
can study so when you think of what you
can do with genomic data analysis once
you know how to analyze it you really
have a huge potential of understanding
uh you know validation of specific types
of variation that we can observe
including human disease and in response
to different treatments and ultimately
this trend will continue so knowing and
acquiring the skills to analyze such
data is a critical skill that you will
take away with you to be able to
contribute to the continuous exploration
and understanding of how genomes work
what do they encode in terms of genes
and how can those genes be studied in
terms of regulation of these complex
conditions like cancer like infectious
diseases like neuroscience and others
so after you heard this brief
introduction into the topic of genomics
i would like to pass it on to dr raghav
who will speak about the other sessions
in the program and kind of talk about
more of the practice